come on what happened besides an
infection of the face and I tell you I'm
sorry you're just squeezing you so hard
you'll get sore on your face now I'm
alone spots on my face I don't watch
from dude from life you know I'm like
I'm fired the [ __ ] up Brian why I'm
fired up don't slap your stupid faces
man I get excited I wanna slap yours and
and you know what I'm gonna do what I'm
gonna slap your teeth crooked again try
what's annoying me what your stupid
[ __ ] straight teeth I know I think
you're better man I'm just saying
the skyline has been evil now and if you
smacked me I'll do what's called saluted
I'll salute it bank salute blood salute
yeah I don't close my eyes anymore when
I see something come at me I here's what
you should do with your size and your
strength and you'll get away with it
somebody ever gives you a hard time
yeah you pick them up you go wait till
they go to the bathroom with no cameras
you pick them up when they're at the
urinal you squeeze them so hard they
have a soaker they put a pan of slop new
person when they're taking a piss you
can't stop no we don't stop now so you
pick him up and it's just like a
sprinkler uh-huh you make him do it all
over the bath but you have to you can
also squeeze them until they lose
consciousness and then they wake up
choke him out no no be more than their
body would be more demeaning just to
pick them up and then throw them all
around throw the room gets all wet I
like that and then you feel like that
you squeeze their torso until they can't
breathe in the Navy scope with that what
are they what are they gonna say he
picked me up and he squeezed me until I
passed out no guy then flicked my dick
when I was finished and that's where
that bothered the most yes or you pull
their pants down and you think and you
leave a little like one of those little
flag a little toothpick flag in his
crack well they come in like sliders it
says nice to meet you have a good day
have a good day have a good he's never
gonna tell anyone it for ya don't be a
dumbass
right he's never gonna tell anyone that
that happened or what if I were him
write the note and then fold it up like
I did in elementary I'm hand it to
Michael you know you're mine when you
played paper football yeah I'd give him
that
I'd like he goes what the [ __ ] me openly
I go have a nice day I like that
although I'd like you to roll the note
I'd like you to dip it in some butter
and I want you to stick it right up his
[ __ ] he's gonna come to and go I got
something on my [ __ ] and he's gonna
pull it out and it's gonna be a note
that says I was here it says I was here
job was here
keep it shout was it real there's no way
he's gonna go to the cops and say all
right I was peeing guy picked me up
squeezed me until I lost consciousness
any super-soak the bathroom and then he
hear em I hear em me with levar any and
he gently put a note up my ass no it's
no one's gonna [ __ ] say that
no it's like that murderous monster
Terry Crews you ain't snitching uh no
you murdered those correct parathe very
good if a true nobody squeeze in Terry
Crews uh well they did they did squeeze
in it's done not unconscious but they
see snitched
I got a I've never looked at him the
same oh I'm out I'm out great
hey exec you see me just grab my fat
dick I'm like come on I'm not gonna out
ya know I'm not gonna go on a tour and
that guy guys guys no I know got even
apologize like my bad man must be a
great guy yeah Jimmy Graham dudes do
remember that that mafia that guy was
the British mafia guy that guy who
collected debts and the guy didn't have
his dad a movie oh no this was on I
think was Vice you told me about that ah
yeah
and he goes all right time to get [ __ ]
and the guy he just a grown man and the
other guy pulled his pants down and and
[ __ ] the other guy they took Holroyd
yeah but I think he's marrying math yeah
that'll do it but that's also you're
also sir you're also a big thug and
you're very gay big gay though I think
I'm gonna have to teach you a lesson
then you get it hard he's like this how
we do it in London that's know the gays
do it when they collect money that's
right there's nothing wrong with that
you're a big gay thug you're big big a
thug need loves Tim that's fine now be I
got a I'm having a good day got a call
from a big gay hashtag big I got a call
from my agent
you know when they call you there's
nothing worse than when you get a call
you're expecting some sort of news and
they kind of go how's the kid Manik good
if anything was wrong yeah I mean you'd
be
that's right what are we doing Tommy
with that like what I got bills what's
up what's up it's like just check-in I'm
like no news nah man enough then just
see how you're doing
all right they called me back when you
had some news that's right can't
announce in the news yet they're coming
back some tasty news for me so I thought
you know what I'm an eating all day
worked out hard - yeah super hard yeah
and I thought I've been eating there's a
food truck outside our studio right now
and they had all these signs all over
like Shark Tank ABC NBC just world's
best and then there's a fat lobster on
the side I went oh yeah lobster rolls in
there oh boy it's today the cheat day
for me so I went in there do you look at
the price a little overzealous whatever
lobster rolls those lobster rolls are
$18 each Wow let me tell you this
it was live Maine laughs they better be
[ __ ] good bro they better be fast
lobster rolls I don't have truck I
better change my things called I think
it's called cousins Maine lobsters are
they out there now or the knobs are no
they're out there right now right
they're not stairs yeah I post a video
do like a man scram story you tell me Oh
roll you're gonna get there's a reason
why they're $18 drive the wrong describe
the small soft bun right soft bun soft
buttery bun toasted toasty buns
Smallville Bunya got small bun why cuz
there's a mount of sea bug baby it's see
papa
basically the tail oh I don't what the
[ __ ] that is
that's what I know oh that looks [ __ ]
delicious water on that bad boy the best
I've never had it thought wow $36 pricey
for two of them yeah we're gonna
celebrate then you know what I did you
know I did I'm always talking about
health stuff like that I just crushed
two lobster rolls
mosey on over to Whole Foods I went [ __ ]
it
Oh you ever had you ever had the
gingerbread cookies that whole food how
they're if your gingerbread lover
they're so goddamn sath yeah like your
grandma baked them this morning
but for everybody yes and I get four of
those yeah my sister my sister spent a
lot of time on a gingerbread house with
my mother one time they made a beautiful
gingerbread house yeah and and the
destroyer came in crushed it
I I had to I had to break it apart and
they're kind of silly you know kind of
silly
I make them then they get all hard but
I'm telling if you if you like
gingerbread cookies Whole Foods makes
the freshest gingerbread that lobster
tail looks simply divine oh dude I'm
telling you then I like that part
all these award-winning and then you can
get it I got it Connecticut style and
then there's I think Boston style Boston
as the mayonnaise and I don't [ __ ] with
that I like every mobster butter period
lobster butter roll bugs of the sea bro
bugs of the did you listen to Rogen he
had a vegan doctor a functional medicine
doctor who was vegan and a functional
medicine godlike wrestler who I think is
the Crisco sir
yeah he's the keto best you know and III
have to say after all the talk I have
fallen on the side more of the vegan in
other words I'm still gonna eat meat but
I don't feel so good when I eat fatty
foods and fatty saturated fats and I've
thought about it and I was like you know
overall I believe that you live probably
longer when you they argued back and
forth classic example of two people
citing all kinds of studies and I
thought it was you are you gonna go
vegan no propose of that big of a life
change nah I'll eat a lot of vegetables
now eat a you know a mostly yeah yeah no
[ __ ] I'm not gonna eat a lot of meat
though and a yard no no here's what I
was thinking you know Charles Poliquin
who our boy Chris Bell remember Chris
Bell when he said I said what's your
cholesterol and he goes like 320 he only
eats me and I went that's pretty really
high yeah and he goes nah not according
to Charles public when I'm not listening
to doctors Charles Poliquin is a famous
strength coach I want to I want you to
hear this now he's a famous strength I
don't hold on strength coach not just
that dr. notch is that he's he's coached
more he's woke up a coach more gold
medalists you're gonna love this does
not matter you're gonna love this he's
coached more gold medallist than anybody
else and he is so let's keep going and
he has looked at all the PubMed and he
believes and just basically eats meat
and nuts and all that
he died at 57 three days ago and I was
like did he die through he died three
days ago and I believe it's a heart
attack and I was like well me well you
know I mean and I and I tried to eat the
way he was talking about it and I felt
like complete [ __ ] everybody's different
I did I felt sluggish I'm not saying
that's a killer but I'm saying that over
all day what man if you if you mean Jay
were talking about this more see out if
you show me a video of what they do
those animals before every meal I could
eat vegan I mean but I kind of can block
it out and go through it I know what
you're saying I think about that too
yeah
but different Leegin vegan I feel I feel
a little weak is the only thing I do I
need a little meat I like I like fish
and she ever done like real vegan you do
now could be a as an athlete Katoon as
yeah as an athlete I don't think you
could do vegan for you Jay chill did yes
he did one the best welterweights in the
world yes he did could you when you were
trained I don't know I've never done it
long but didn't you crave me I mean I
crave sugar it doesn't I mean you know
I'm saying like yeah I create I don't
know because everyone has their body's
used to everything if you got rid of
coffee
I'd have withdraws if you got rid of
sugar I have withdrawals if you were to
Brad AB withdrawals we don't know
because we've been so conditioned yeah
to the lifestyles and the food that
we're eating yep it's uh it's a little
strange I'd have to say it's a raging
food is such an emotional strange thing
boots the biggest kind of like I don't
have a drug problem on I have a drinking
problem
like Rogan was asked me to do silver
October I you don't nothing
I don't I got nothing to really if
you're if silver October for me would be
I guess not eating bread and sugar
I got boring as that yeah bread and
sugar anyway cuz my condition I do
because my welcome to skin condition but
that would be the hardest thing for me I
mean my addictions food yeah
that's where it gets tricky for a big
guy super trick I'm dying I wash down
those lobster rolls and those four
gingerbread cookies and I'm sloshing
around my status almond milk latte
fantastic fantastic you know why I'm not
a [ __ ] yeah I'm not a raging [ __ ] who
eats just plans give me give me some
[ __ ]
sleep give me some coffee and give me
just a balance you know as long as I
work out I'm good like if I work out in
the morning I can basically get away
with I think you said the other day and
I did the same thing I ate just I just
added some rice and chicken about
fantastic no I love that felt fantastic
dude I ordered sugar fish last night the
sushi to the crib just as good when you
eat it there man comes in a nice
condensed box they actually very proper
never should I yeah yeah well done yes
you're on 18 yeah they do host mates
you don't say pretty quick tube took
about 20 minutes to get to the crib huh
and kids just as good comes in a nice
little box that's what the box came and
that's exactly what I had last night and
I felt fantastic after it look at that
that looks like a delicious little box
felt fantastic now I get to the gym this
morning it's a pack class they have to
[ __ ] my brains out oh boy yeah I did and
I'm gonna need some time and everyone so
we keep knocking on the door someone in
it he's had it boxing stolen in here
that's a box a little it's that little
bathroom that first of all it's not a
private little bath I barely fit not
private you barely fit it's stained oh
when you walk out there's no ashes there
so when I walked out everyone's warmed
up and they knew that the big man had
dropped a deuce
Papa laid it down in there I was in the
for a while my lips red cause biting my
bottom lip but I do work in there cuz I
gotta get on these I gotta do work you
were fighting your bottom probably work
yeah a little bite stain you know a bite
stain on the bottom of the ship sweats
ah boy ah the big man the big man
dropped a deuce but you know what I do
like a circle I sprayed so much aerosol
I feel like they'd rather have the [ __ ]
smell naps but that aerosol helps makes
us know I said candy face is my like a
[ __ ] lemon somebody springs some lemon
and lemon on Serano poo yeah I tried
making better but when you okay just
you're right under the clash hit just
hit the streets and it was like well
this [ __ ] boy for the day yeah let that
went for me dude my son my son easy
little boy and he hasn't quite figured
out though wiping the poo think so he'll
it's a disaster well it's a disaster I
have to I have to declare a hazmat
situation dude you know what I'm excited
for it's my favorite holiday to
Halloween it's Halloween laughs dude
Halloween you Halloween well you're 51
spray
not your thing I'm dressing up you want
to know what my costume is let me take
us to your costume oh yeah what are you
is it from a movie no TV show would tell
me not being the Goldberg guy that
homeland shirt I got is so pathetic on
the gym coaching Goldberg god dammit I
was like the canal Ament your school I
get it your parents are broke but do
something you're good show up in his pop
water [ __ ] football jersey Mike hey
bro that's not an outfit that's not a
costume
we were that every [ __ ] Saturday you
know what I'm gonna be you like it
you're gonna be just like him I'm not a
man you're just as a woman
yep and it's from a drama TV show drama
TV show now is the is it is a
transgender in the TV show no it's an
actual woman the TV show dad there's a
lot of women TV shows give me a hint
what Network cool oh you're playing your
boy Jerry Tim Backus role know his name
Jerry came back to talk about Tambor
Jeffrey Campbell now a year for a year
he knew he knew me three just didn't
know my wife's name because this is a
nice full name yeah it's Jeffrey Tambor
and I'm Jerry it's Jeffrey tell you
playing him on who I'm sure not I sure
you know I don't watch my playing I'm
gonna be I'm dressing up as a handmade
from hands maids tale oh yeah that's a
big show I mean yeah I'm gonna be a
Handmaid's Tale and I'm gonna be a
handmaid so which means I'm I'm look
which means you just need that red thing
and then the thing over your face that's
correct sir that'd be cool man it's
gonna be [ __ ] hilarious and I'm sure
people will find it offensive that's a
good you'll find an offensive have you
watched it yes I've been watched on of
Hulu the reason it's such a good show is
it's all it's a dystopian show like it's
about do you notice about the idea and
in a way it
it's it goes on in societies and one way
or another even are treated that way to
an exploit Lindsay Lohan's lot how
liberal well good punch of the faith if
she did got punched in the [ __ ] face
my family and I were dressing up as The
Incredibles
I'm mr. incredible that's my girls the
mama incredible funny and then tigers
the [ __ ] fast game and you really
don't need a costume because you're all
muscular just paint me all red and put a
mask on now I made a mistake two years
ago and dressed up as a panda well
here's the thing by we just heard buzz
panda price should have a pan of furry
outfit on so I said my girl do the
makeup and put pigtails in my long hair
look like a deer no problem
well I start to sweat and then it starts
to fade down I look like a complete
[ __ ] psycho and no one no one talked
me the entire day I was like what the
[ __ ] that my girl goes might be your
face it what's wrong with it
I have no idea she showed me a picture
of it what the [ __ ] man why would you
tell me why I could tell my son was like
it'll skittish - I'm like what the [ __ ]
what sounds like all black one time
Brennan came to my house in like it was
like 11:00 at night you had to drop
something off or pick something up it's
like when we kind we'd we just like six
months if that and you should place
umbrella my wife and I answer the door
and he's looming over us and boots and
we had our we didn't we had bare feet on
and he looked at me oh hey do it because
I'm gonna pick that [ __ ] you know what
I could kill you both right now what no
I could just go goos to your heads and
you would die do we know this do we know
how easy it would be for me to kill both
of you this is so funny I think was like
oh my god and then afterwards she goes
that was weird and I go but I but it was
true like you know he could kill us he
goes hey I don't care I don't know why
did he see us he fighters I don't know
why I did that
no it was hilarious you were laughing so
hard a few time so crunk about Halloween
though house is all made up kiddos into
Halloween now watch a scary movie every
night every novel ystem of fades
list of my faves have you seen delivers
from evil
no I have not uh what's name banner
banner banner banner he's [ __ ] I
based on the story rich and I believe
all of it I love is a cop who's breaking
this case with this this person's [ __ ]
haunted and it is such a well decorated
yeah that guy the demon possesses him he
[ __ ] people up - mean [ __ ] people up
like he's super scary look at the
writing on him yeah that's a scary ass
movie man takes place in New York
training every scene but it's good damn
that looks Edgar Ramirez is in it as
well hmm what do that come out probably
two years ago holy [ __ ] that's not good
look at that guy
so this movie's legit man really there's
that one
I just watched that last night and then
tonight I'm gonna fire up seem sinister
with my boy who's that guy that is scary
- he's not in the movie I don't know a
[ __ ] egg have you seen are you a
scary movie guy chin yeah wait time have
you seen delivers from evil not yet no
sinister sketchy sinister though has mr.
scare an amazing actor cine sinister
scariest [ __ ] not that [ __ ] that will
that she bothers me she's not afraid
she's not coming that scares me
who is that guy that's scary he's that
the original movie who's the guy in it
Ethan Hawke if and he's a writer he's an
author yeah oh he's so good in that bro
I'm gonna tell you this right now I'm
[ __ ] telling you this and I've never
been more serious in that piece of [ __ ]
right there comes in my house and [ __ ]
with my kids yep they better be ready
because I'm jumping through the gates of
Hell and there will be a fight and who's
gonna win
Brian Katz what they walk it's Bryan
Callen isn't Bryan Callen anymore he's
not the kid anymore what Celeste he
becomes a [ __ ] movie scene I start
conjuring 2 and that's stupid today that
stupid [ __ ] with the big black mouth
I'll dive right in real [ __ ] mouth
I'll go down time I've done a fuzzy way
have you seen the nun chin from
conjuring soon yeah no bro
god dammit 42:51 not a nun
oh the actual not the movie no no no
haven't seen it but I talk about play
the [ __ ] trailer it's in a restaurant
what it's in a different language isn't
it wait no bro it's in [ __ ] English
the nun in a different language is this
a new movie yeah I mean I was in theater
I think he's in theaters right now it
came out like a month the guy didn't
show this to me make sure you watch this
to the end
there's that stupid cut that's English
Jen I know you're but what did you see I
saw nuns are sexy JC whiskers
this is the darkest chapter this is the
darkest rap sheet down
God is here so we came out in September
a month ago
basically yeah she's behind you they're
always behind you
it was move so slow - I have chilly up
there right now I just got chills I'll
be on yeah you [ __ ] um I'll tell right
now I'm not going down there to check
that [ __ ] out oh wow dude Brian
bats can make sure you watch the mom sit
up jiggetts it's alright I'm [ __ ]
ready make sure you watch to the end
let's see what happens she's gonna pop
up oh oh that's probably it
that was good though right yeah I have
some I have goose bumps even on my head
Wow do you know what goose bumps are
from an evolutionary standpoint chance
that would be that would be our hair
standing on end
we don't hair hair anymore or here
standing we do have here in other words
like when you get good here it's the
hair your hair your hair would be you
like the way a dog gets scared or your
hair would go up and so that's what
goose bumps are that you're what we do
up here it's a memory see those tears
pop up yeah and do you know what animal
primates are naturally afraid of all
primates are [ __ ] really afraid of
it's really weird
Chan snakes yeah snakes and so when
people have a phobia of snakes and
they've never really been around snakes
that is a genetic memory they believe
hmm same reason why we're scared of the
darkness and shadows dark is it cavemen
yeah like it was not good at night
that's when [ __ ] went down now I turn
the lights off I'm on hold on um every
bit of 35 guys I'm 35 I'm well into my
30s yeah when I turn the lights off at
night and I'm alone and I get to go
upstairs in my bedroom
I've run no I know I'm [ __ ]
I'm running from a serial killer are you
running from a Coast ghost yeah yeah
Cyril I could turn around like well what
are you unless you have a gun I'm gonna
kill you I'm gonna choke you
yeah but ghosts right mm don't care so I
run from ghost now
in a pool by myself do I think there's a
great white gonna be released from the
bottom I still do and I hurry up out of
them I don't have that problem but I
cannot swim in the ocean with reckless
abandon and when I was in Costa Rica I
knew that there are large Crocs out
there and even though there are American
crocodiles and not as aggressive there
crocodiles so I had a problem I had a
problem I think it'd be so cool if like
the government came out I was like we've
been doing a research for the last
hundred years the ghoster is real as
[ __ ] how great would that be
if Trump just released that news or some
[ __ ] if they can't even agree with all
the data that certain foods are good
versus other food how we're gonna agree
with coast are you are you a guy who
believes in ghosts you're into that [ __ ]
chin before I feel that does it runs
deep in Korean culture I don't know I
think Asian culture right not
necessarily gets produced like the
scariest movies
yeah cream movies are really good yeah
you should still haven't seen freaking
train to Busan which is a zombie movie
but still I like it check it out I saw
zombies are more realistic than ghosts
probably us I saw really I mean a
[ __ ] tear another name it's about the
devil who comes into a small town it's
sad too but it's this devil is [ __ ] game
I'll find it for a second in it um the
wind wailing yeah her that's food dig it
was on Netflix - dude is still on that
play think it's not on there anymore
their train to Busan is yes what's that
about it's a fun it's a fun a we're
whaling on and see if watch the whaling
for Sue Traylor yeah what's this a movie
that you super sleepy Korean Hormuz that
will scare you senseless yeah click on
that chin I'm sure one of them is
whaling I saw tail the tail the two
sisters I've also seen that I saw del
was more like a gory what does that say
China that's the way to Korea puts out
the scroll down chin
yeah what their show get it the scary
movies this one the music is amazing on
but the movies not that great it's like
confusing but it's it is scary and
confuse them subtitles with subtitles
I'm out keep going they're all subtitled
I know
subtitles out on mine yes Cal using anti
battle
yeah that's just two strikes never seen
death Bell well it's their number two
we're spring corridors I think I like
the title
this is morals all the devlins like a
murder movie and it's dark don't super
dark
is it good I think it's so good but it
might be too much if you're not used to
like hardcore gory movies and it's real
life you've seen the hostel it's it's
kind of like that but you're gonna be
more like emotionally that hostel
bothers me because I know like that the
hostel and the hostel like twos like
those movies where people like sex
trafficking and they murder them yeah
that's so realistic I don't like that
meaning I like this is what this movies
like it's like alien stuff yeah killing
people and people you love not in its
gory it's it's see that's not scary to
me that's just yeah people said that's
fetishy that's like for people - yeah
the apartment never heard of eight the
name keep going this is not a good list
boy Malloy that sounds more Vietnamese
you but you've never seen any of these
Jin only tail the two sisters I want if
they're all on that doesn't seem like a
sexy her shoot and what your eyes evil
Korean way to your eyes still good be
yeah bro they are is that no ghosts come
to you when you're asleep in the music
this is like a joke movie she's cute
she's pretty shits like she likes cute
fart no I'll tell you what for my money
it still holds up over time always has
is uh Texas Chainsaw
with Jessica Biel I've never seen a fun
every small D movie man really Jessica
Biel yeah you've never seen another
original one I got her one like 70s yeah
it was for you out there dude you know
you've seen the one with Jessica Biel I
don't think so [ __ ] it's good I might
have her as Miley number one number two
in Hollywood she's up I think about it I
did a rear view high school shout out to
Boulder um
shout out to Boulder some in the water
in the masses Boulder
have you seen House of Wax with Paris
Hilton no no no no she just makes a
cameo in it but Jessica Biel in that
movie's ridiculous she's just she's
younger basically perfect
yeah she's young yeah she's great in
center - you realize how good of an
actor she isn't sinner like Jesus Christ
yes she's a dime he dying
lord have mercy gentlemen realized one
thing yes she's collaborated miming
collaborate she's had sex with Justin
Timberlake another dime pieces yeah yeah
we're all trolls compared I'd like to be
a fly on the wall I fly in the WOD means
I'd like to be a grown man your closet
Jacqueline yes yes or or I'd like to
just be involved and if you're like oh I
got it if you want a piece of Jessica I
go to just you gotta give him a kiss a
kiss problem who's watching nobody's
ball press all right even if you want to
film it yeah sometimes I eat food and
I'd be the boom mic guy from Boogie
Nights right be sweating be like mouth
just salivating exactly that's funny
because I won't eat that duck egg but I
would make out with Justin Timberlake
God he said hey Bryan you got to make
out with Justin Timberlake he's a dude
or you can eat that Vietnamese
got a stock egg would you look at that
no just like a lick why do you have to
bring a pop why do you have to go all
the way down to his shirt because how
easy is it to go oh I'll give just a
peck on the lips and so let me [ __ ] his
girl That's not me
doesn't know I make out just not
interesting yours on the bend around
like it it's gotta give it like like
you're licking like like [ __ ] you dude
like you have an ice cream cone I know
what it means Phil's usko oh [ __ ] no ah
my back oh now hold on you are my ice
cream cones Mountain [ __ ] huh that's
what you got to do is that what do I get
for that you get the cleanses girl I get
to disinfect that whole surface right no
what do you mean no the middle of beaten
cheeks get dug out of him behind get the
[ __ ] out of the old and sink a soapy and
dip your tongue in there you're out of
here what do I get for that everybody
has as soon as you do your goddamn
thanks B go ahead and you get the entire
night to the wee hours of the morning if
I was younger I'd say yes but now it's
like you know it's really I feel like in
the back nine might as well it's like
young you have your whole career ahead
of you now it's like you're said I would
need money I need some other [ __ ] Wow
yeah if I could marry her around oh good
what do you got weird
I got no dude look man don't do that
with you don't let me do that noise man
oh look I got a snow I got a snow cone
oh wow some tripping god damn it's all
y'all doing you sleep with a girl you
like you've done you're a [ __ ] dude yep
I would I
CJ yeah okay ha I'm gay super gay see
you bro I'm gonna take your girl from
here on out see you at 7 a.m. yeah yeah
yeah just like give me a Ferrari for the
night I'm gonna come back this me
scratch month there's gonna be your
mouth wishing me [ __ ] up you're
causing me [ __ ] up man yeah not me I'm
gonna hit her but that's gonna stay a
little rough yeah I was gonna say I
don't know man I read this girl was
gonna be all chaps me all exhausted long
times really hot girl my acting class
back in the day and I said something
like I was trying to I liked her and I
go I said I would have sex with you I
would have sex with you I would just
have sympathy for 3 hours
they all do Brian
they all as in yeah dudes yeah it's like
there's nothing you're gonna do that I
haven't been food I was with now like
you're not some power I was with a buddy
and uh we were getting coffee and a hot
girl walk by us we're in the middle of
conversation goes he had sunglass and
goes does this we're outside a heart
pretty hot like an 8 in LA walks by and
wearing a little Miller conversations
you like tell us whoa whoa whoa and I go
well I'm literally in the middle of a
discussion ago
what what what Manny is just like just
take it in I go you a construction
worker never seen a girl before [ __ ]
you do don't say that so what are you
here doing right what the [ __ ] you're
too old for this
yeah like I don't I love friends who
don't whoa whoa whoa whoa look at that
it's like what yeah and like a scene at
Chipotle after I did Rogen shows Graham
Chipotle before I came here and there
was this girl came in ridiculous body
like I almost felt bad for it that she
was so curvy and she's in these jeans
and her astrocyte
titties just like just pretty face
decent face but her body's like predict
you can't hide a she she wear a plastic
bag and be like dude you're disaster so
she walks and you can tell right I was
just like yeah there's like all these
like they worked for some like you know
just guys in their [ __ ] to work outfit
and they're there like they work for the
city that the yellow aprons on and I
hear Gus go mmm
yeah guys I'd love a bite of that and
then they go around I literally I die
turnaround scheme the worst-looking like
oh [ __ ] man what is wrong with you guys
any what you like about would you like
to buy to that yeah what are you gonna
do yeah what do you do you know what the
kind of guy she looks like what she
wants to [ __ ] not you
[ __ ] saps yeah like what's wrong with
you man I think it's a my feel bad for
though I felt bad for I was like goddamn
s just a blessing a curse
you shaped like a goddamn Bugatti it
would have read a curse a shove these
big old pouty lips that we're all
natural she had no makeup it was like
girl it's what the French call on
disaster say on disaster I mean I don't
know I'm built for one thing yeah that's
right and those gentlemen won't do it
yeah they want you all to know that
they're not gay taps into there that's
the other thing they bond they want to
make sure so you guys know so you know I
would [ __ ]
yeah pretty cool man I think every man
on the planet feels that way but you
don't need to be super lame about yeah
yeah like take it easy now did I buy her
extra guacamole
I did I did can I buy you some extra
guacamole please would you like to sit
down the podcast here's some guacamole I
must slide into your DMS Hey with a
coupon code for japones so you think of
me that's right the gentleman move it's
a gentleman no tell me painfully
beautiful really her body this is this
is this I think you should be you should
you need to fly to Miami right now and
being a DJ Khalid bill like video like
video no go to DJ Khalid and I think
it's Khalid Khalid or Khalid I think
it's Khalid with uh but the opening
scene this girl I thought oh no brainer
it's no brainer
I think it's no brainer oh no it's I'm
the one it's I'm the one but I was think
about that this girl do you think she's
happy she got this role this one yep
open sing the girls coming in on a horse
it's literally in the first 30 seconds
has the biggest cans you've ever seen
but she's on the horse just ready get
your dick out Brian but then she's
walking into the house in a thong really
and I thought this is someone's daughter
don't worry about the legs she's told
her whole family shoes in the new DJ
video and then she's again
she's impossibly hot we the best
this song is impossible not to dance -
yo crush that Bieber does not miss every
hit every never never made a bathroom
when he features on it now let me ask
him
you think Bieber took them tips for a
test-drive
he's gotten bigger cuz when I I'm in a
2017 abs horseshoes look at Bieber's
look at his muscles what's a video full
of big titty girls
yes 51 year old gay man I want to get
some tax Wow yeah I want to start
singing
wow that was a take away he just looks
he looks he looks like Aggies grown up
didn't even notice I notice the girls
with the impossible jugs yeah and that
was the point of the video I didn't see
he made this very way to saw the the
young smooth boy with the shaved head
she is something else by the way no no
no no no baby straight now she there she
you mean he's um yeah she's no son
dude she's fresh I'll be really good
you're right Bieber Metta put on this
mystery guy try to be straight she's
fresh start since the outfit she's
wearing I like what is that gold you
think like the guy doesn't notice her
body yes she's the ballad the trashy but
other than that like what that's what I
like guys to do that they go little
trash you for me I'm always like oh
you're a little gay then obviously that
has 1 billion views is that good
I don't know there's one bit do they
have ty don't believe that is that
really true that's true no way there's
no way
yeah I don't believe that welcome to the
new age I don't believe that 1 billion
views Drake's songs also get 1 billion 1
billion so this was the name of techie
atashi 6 9 Akashi
Takashi has a video with this girl and
in how much do they making for those
videos they when it hits a billion money
you're getting there how much of people
on tailing consideration a lot of times
though I don't know if they own it
Bieber has his own YouTube like page
channel doesn't matter people go to
youtube like us we don't cut it was his
thing right no you do do you have could
you cuz you have to well if you want to
see Brian and Brendan do fine kid you
have to go to Brian Brennan spy in the
yeah you [ __ ] hear that yep now you
Howard yeah do old how much does YouTube
pay you if you get a billion views dude
I don't know if you want to do that $1
for 25 views no way
yeah that's right really but what is a
billion get you can 1,000 YouTube
impressions get it could be one point
one cent or ten dollars it's one dollar
for every 1,000 advertising impressions
you would generate there is 1,000 views
one cent 10,000 views 10 dollars 100,000
is a hundred dollars a million is one
thousand ten million ten thousand a
billion is that's a $1 CPM though
that ain't low values 1 million alright
so there you go seven cent CPM where
that's so it's between one and seven I
think that's a ripoff on the artist yes
what else you gonna do I think that the
artist should share and get more revenue
than that I don't stuff cuz they host
they do everything for you just do it
yeah baby hold on to the you don't
notice to your website though do that
you do that it is true though that there
that there's a lot of its concentrated
right and and that's one of the things
that they talk about well you know how
there are few companies that have a
massive amount of power over artists or
anybody with expression iTunes
they look at you too when one company
has that much power it's pretty tough
but there's a reason why they have that
much power because they're a great
servant they're great service so there's
kind of there's a to play there but also
artists need artists podcasters
entertainers in general have to adapt to
those times because artists go what the
[ __ ] man when we did albums we make $7
now very cool that was in 2001
no one's buying albums so now you gotta
upload to YouTube you got to do you know
you got to be on iTunes now it's more
your singles a marketing thing to put
get people in the seats for when you
tour yeah and then you have to have good
merch right the Bieber makes most of
money off merch torn most of his money
comes from merch Kanye West most his
money comes from merch so all like the
now like you know Taylor Swift when
she's on tour she's making [ __ ]
boatloads of cash it's not because their
singles number-one their main UI makes
decent money but it's almost like an
infomercial for the tomorrow or anything
right and I think the stand-ups same way
I mean I think special a lot of times is
you're gonna make even more money on the
road it's gonna get people Hanabusa I
was just going over this with with with
Justin for my special he's you know
being a stickler going back and forth to
show trying stuff on it I I don't care
yeah but literally did if that's the
second point I do not care right that is
just a marketing tool correct
infomercial feather my man I can do this
come watch this down the road that's
right all ISM you know it's just market
that's right but that but that's so
that's where that's with you know moat
so a lot of times podcast is to if
you're a comic you don't have a podcast
entertainer I have a podcast well now
you don't we get to steer our narrative
to our fans or to the public in general
we get it so if some time that says you
know Brian said this this is this you
might well know I'm gonna go in my
studio and this is exactly what I said
yeah yeah just a good thing but also but
also for some comics were such
elite-level don't need it but if you
don't have a podcast this is also kind
of a way where people relate to and then
in return is tickets on the road right
that's right cuz they know you yeah
instead of just being the sky but well
it's the first look instead of just
being a guy that's just at the Calm East
or just doing specials yeah they know
you as your comedy yes but I'm sure you
feel the same way when I go into any
City they know me they'd they know I'm a
silly [ __ ] goose alright there's
gonna be dick jokes there's gonna be
some references there Tom yeah there's
gonna you know well it's the first time
I think in the history of artists for
our nars that they we have this much
control over our brand and this much
control over you know basically
how to get people daliyah he's got those
two specials on Netflix but his
Instagram is he can just post one thing
and he feels you know a theater he's
that you know why she's the best at
social media right he's the smartest
mind most creative guy in social media
you watch it I don't watch a lot of my
friends stuff I don't watch there's some
of my best friends I don't watch stuff
Chris D'Elia I watched it yeah [ __ ]
there yeah it's original it's great
content short exactly here's my have you
seen this Mark Wahlberg thing yeah it's
amazing I could not stop laughing right
now I was working on the gym I'm like
dude I am like dude what the [ __ ] are
you doing he's so good at it and so now
I just sold out the Wilbur four times in
a row yeah four times then that in a sec
last show and it has to be on a bigger
venue yeah yeah it's so cool that is
what it is yeah it's all the thing about
Rokan yeah
Rogan opción Instagram if you know he's
not he's not Chris D'Elia he's not he's
not social media funny like that's not
his thing
Brogan's one finds people I know but
that's nice thing but on the podcast
it's the biggest show in the world it's
literally the biggest channel awesome
this conversation with some my buddies
because or some people I work with who
work for these big Network stuff like
that I said there's not I'm doing Rogen
on Tuesday now listen we can well no no
you don't realize that's bigger than
anything you're gonna book for me
there's nothing close yeah any I'm doing
my bit one of my best friends yeah so
whatever you have going on there's
nothing bigger than that nothing nothing
who's read more about that they're like
really I'm like what do you what rock
are you living in right or it's like
when they asked us do certain radio
shows mm-hmm not just do it on here yeah
I would I do that right so old-school it
is it is it's a good time it's an
exciting time in that sense it's up if
you adapt to the tip you attack
if not I'm amazing try to feel your
Matty's dat how how still a lot of TV
and a lot of like the traditional
networks have not caught up and you can
see it and you Det this is why one of
the reasons Netflix came along and
changed the whole game for everyone had
a conversation with it were the dude
deals with the Netflix their show back
they spent over a billion dollars like
content over a billion dollars he makes
my show back that well they're fine
but they're so backed up with that let's
say you were gonna do a project them you
don't come out to 2022 now do that 21
2022 oh well because you have something
they day you they're quite so much
contact and they go you know you can't
put it all out yeah and so you wonder
about that too you wonder about whether
or not after a while it becomes a
saturation point you that then like what
I like about the marketplace is after a
while netflix becomes too big you might
get lost in a large pond so you want to
go with somebody else who has their own
kind of way of going about it so in all
the pens yeah I mean obviously Netflix
is great and I love Netflix I use them
every night and for for comedy specials
and go watch Joe Rogan's right now he
really says I saw it last night it's
brilliant and for certain guys like that
yeah man yeah you know they're putting
up billboards are doing the promotion
but if you're a smaller scale guy yeah
you get long gimmicks eat the [ __ ] up
yeah
there's no billboards you're your family
and friends are gonna see it hopefully
you get put in that queue with the big
dogs and someone sees it but your tops
lost and you have navigate through that
yeah let's go back to the archer I know
a lot of people with their Netflix
specials that you know kind of just came
and went because it's just there's a lot
and a you know but if it's good to find
I think so I think normal life I agree I
come with a good product I don't give a
[ __ ] just dude wherever it's at I don't
they'll [ __ ] if it's good it exudes look
at Sebastian on Showtime exactly that's
special they've ever done Jesus why
Sebastian is so [ __ ] big well his
special was one of the bat it's
hilarious it's amazing yeah Sebastian
has always been that's a classic example
of a guy who works his ass off keeps his
head down when he was a waiter all those
years always doing stand-up always
working always right and keeping it
simple
never stopped keeping out of trouble the
best great the past the past Lee the
best never ever do it bring me down you
all best gym where you run Halloween do
you dress up
besides luring people men do you Lord
late 30s and 40s but your dress up as
Ted Bundy and Lord males into your
[ __ ] basement
apartment that would be the best day to
do that in cooks Korean barbecue humans
and that smells good come on in I'm
giving out free samples samples samples
mm-hmm celebrating new ones are you the
guy who gives out full fruit the kids or
are either guy you're one of two guys I
think kids you're not giving out healthy
snacks no or you the guy that gives out
an apple like an ass I'm rather his old
lady I want to make [ __ ] you man
nah one time out of the year you given
out these [ __ ] granny smith apples
Oh cereal with some almond milk you know
or we give change like all right thanks
for the 37 cents I'm Savin and I know
this but times a chance cuz my
grandmother in in Brooklyn she used to
make a sausage and peppers and eggs eggs
sausage and peppers and here that they
put it in a in an Italian like back in
the day the Brooklyn bread that's
semolina roll that real [ __ ] and she
should leave that up for kids so
actually it was a lot of the Jewish kids
so this is so funny because I would a
pissy abandon her she lived with the
Hasidic Jews and also the Italians and
the Italians lived on one side and the
Jews over there but she knew that the
kids she she ate she was a real snob she
was like the Jews the Hasidic Jews do
not eat the kind the way the Italians do
they don't they don't make food as well
that was just how its boss so she would
lay out she would lay out the sausage
and peppers and stuff for the little
kids as they come by and it was like
candy for them and all the little Jewish
kids kids love that they would freak out
they'd be like holy Sh add sausage yeah
they eat the [ __ ] outta me but she would
always you can't do that like she felt
bad for him she's like you guys I'm out
of [ __ ] B let's say I did this let's say
I hired or let's say I did it made
sausage let's say I'm a meatball sub
Stan of all the kids yeah in 2018 no
parents and that's the shame love and
that's a shame yeah I'm a good dude yes
I have no there's ovary I don't look
skin ever know I like cream never not my
own kid
the crib looks all [ __ ] decorated yes
I started handing out or I hand out
unwrapped starburst
they're not eating no real shame it's a
weird thing that all happened when
tylenol you know that face and you know
that's fake what's that not tylenol but
the razor blade yeah I saw like a legend
but but when tylenol went tired
that rumor when Tylenol got laced with
cyanide
and all those people died I don't know
if you guys remember that I believe it
was the Unabomber that did that I think
no I think so and it was it was in it
was a huge thing yeah town almost all
drug tampering in the Chicago
metropolitan but that's 1980 the victims
had taken town home Brandis in
encapsulate been seven people cyanide if
I'm are very well but that wasn't that
we couldn't believe it and that's when
it was the most unbelievable thing and
it was the end of innocence in that
sense that's when they came up with
tamper resistant bottles and back in the
day you didn't have that so all these
events that would happen some psycho
would do that and it would change and
remember so the other thing is children
on milk cartons
as soon as children started to disappear
the the age of letting your child walk
to school get on his bike and ride
around come home that just went away
because those horror stories they found
a kids remember the guy Joe Walsh who
America's Most Wanted
they found a six-year-old son's head
just his head on the side of the road
and when you read those things everybody
it just changed literally the national
do the college they don't do milk
cartons anymore with kids that's that's
old Anatomy Morgan but what is created
according to a lot of psychologists what
have created was the the helicopter
parent that's what it created the
parents I'm me too and I'm telling you
as a result of that do you think of the
worst well cuz I hear horrible of course
and you see movies know that but that
was not in our in our imagination back
then even though it existed and they
were idle I don't let even my girl's
family I mean my immediate family I did
I like because I let me or I let lopsy
myself my girl my girls mom and then her
stepdad that that's really there's four
people on this earth thing and watch my
kid along yes outside that immediate you
know even extended family cousins aunts
uncles no no I don't let I don't trust
you because you've got a horse you got
to me storm that well you go I don't you
know I don't know how good they're with
kids on if they're well I was yeah I
don't mess there's pros coming
prose you'd watched my kids all again
you're happy about it con your and
terrible at watch them he gets in
trouble he gets hurt or or you [ __ ]
molest well you know the Special Victims
Unit
you know the Special Victims Unit SUV
yeah so I read an article about what
it's like to be a detective who
investigates sex crimes especially with
children stuff like that those people
what it's always a family member or
somebody who's close by and those no
they deal with this [ __ ] like this
dealing about this the woman that shield
and because you get cows to it she's
like well obviously the grandfather is
the one having sex with the the girl or
whatever it is and she's I don't know
seven or eight but they can't prove it
there's no there's a thousand reasons
they can't prove it that they have to
deal with it then they're the
grandfather moves the whole family out
of their jurisdiction and they just got
to deal with it yeah and it was really
interesting that so many of those crimes
don't go report it because no one else
is in the room there's nothing to do
right you can do it all if you get it in
time but ya know and that's what this
holster says rape and stuff is all no
one else is in the room it's a very hard
thing G versus she right she's seven the
qualify pretty witty and creepy as all
that stuff all that stuff climb man
there's not much things make me go to
prison I my life is good there's no way
to piss him off something that we
rappeling my kid or someone does that
[ __ ] of course it's where the only time
where it's where you would kill them
tough not to yep you're some kind of
engine let's get work wait so do you
guys eat out of like the you know you
get salads from salad bar at Whole Foods
or wherever else yeah let's do that
yeah sometimes I get freaked out a
little bit by on that I always feel like
there's crazy people that can just put
stuff in there I haven't worried that if
you know the mushroom section yeah
always were like the poop the people I
should put like well you know what
happen but you know again these are
things that you just take your chance
but over there are cameras everywhere
people but it'd be too late after I take
you I don't think you live life to that
detailed I saw you watching me panicked
if you're then when you get in your car
you think there's a bomb or anything
seems like better is taking risk better
take the risk and not worry you know
what I mean still doable
live
yeah yeah yeah you know if I get high
off mushrooms from Whole Foods I think
it'd be a good time but yeah not me
although I do like the idea of a when
they did a black light on a hotel room
and they found where all the sperm was
there's sperm everywhere every day we
did is they were surprised no I mean
I've been in bed we're not guys not when
the guys like you hoo-hoo jerk off in
sensory deprivation tanks well I told
you it was warm dark I had a I'm still
mad at hard boner you I've had guys from
like shitty deprivation take place but
what the [ __ ] bro you'd give us a bad
name
no no was gonna come like the only one
don't worry about it that's why your
business sucks yeah I jacked off in a
deprivation tank in San Francisco let me
let me get in your tank
yeah up in your tank Wow Audrina after
one person comes oh they filter it to
get him hot tub don't think it ones that
was [ __ ] in a hot tub and busted nuts
in there while you swirling around like
a goddamn human hot dog
what if she gets nasty alright well the
first ones are cats since can't be here
today these are cats current events
that's working because we're filming on
a Thursday yeah
shout out to cat so Mac Miller there's
gonna be a celebration charity concert
for him for his foundation and it's
gonna feature Travis Scott scissor John
Mayer bunch of other acts but in LA
right now like the Greek theater damn it
on Halloween Day
oh damn that's gonna be back Action
Bronson - you guys know a chance the
rapper chance ty dolla sign Anderson PAC
who's from Ventura California big rapper
coming up John Mayer
Miguel schoolboy q this is a Thundercat
trust got
Thai dollar sign dude that's gonna be a
huge concert yeah he they're gonna raise
the shitload of money that's cool man
sure that is such a shame that is such a
[ __ ] shame that dude definitely shame
God beloved by everyone everyone loved
that dude and then it's such a yeah
such a [ __ ] bummer and then when the
cops came in the house you know whoever
called his boys his entourage got rid of
all the drugs all that minutes clean the
place so maybe they didn't want people
know that it was a suicide maybe they
want to just think it was an OD but they
got they cleaned everything what do you
got well Ryan this one you guys are just
kind of talking about this this 81 year
old dude try to strike up a conversation
with a woman outside of a Walmart and
tried to buy her kid you pieces he
offered like a hundred just 200 good
well it's 100 at first then 150 he kept
talking her and then finally two hundred
thousand dollars like God what the [ __ ]
Port Orange Florida so she went again I
said [ __ ] again did he really feel like
reading two hundred two hundred thousand
dollars that's so much money I wonder if
like poor people will be I don't know
it's not that much money chin now I'm
talking about like poor poor people no
I'm saying two hundred thousand for your
kid is not that no candy I'm just saying
there's crazy people out there
I don't think so those don't think
there's crazy people that would sell
their kids sure I mean I'm sure other
people people like that that have a
child who you know yeah I bachelors with
the child at like walk around Walmart
Walmart but yeah there's just crazy
people everywhere that guy in the head
bang I agree I would do it right and
here's the scary thing if he's going up
to random people offering money you
don't think he's done this before horse
they said that the same lady said that
there was a report of him doing it
before to or the cop said that those
report of he's only doing that before
and then when she was trying to pull the
daughter away he grabbed the arm of the
daughter and kissed it on the wrist
that just adds to the creepiness the
reason I don't let my kid walk to school
when he's you know you got to kill that
kid you know you don't worry I can't say
where my kid goes loose anything about
it they intro before but there's a guy
when the kids would get out there's this
guy that's younger black dude who would
come around and
try grabbing the mom one of the kids
thinking a kid away from the mom
why does another kid he would grab the
moms like their titties and stuff
happened a few times
he grabbed my girl she's holding tiger
she ain't grabbed Michael and she turn
around like this and the security guards
there chase him down they arrested him
yeah
how old is this kid that kid is a kid do
you know she the Grameen kid there's a
school right chin yeah so then this do
between frames and grabbing the mom oh
sheesh that doubt the security yeah my
girl tell me what hold up they arrested
him like yeah well how long is you going
away for right maybe forever that would
be good how about forever but you can't
do forever right for what you cannot get
eight assault then I can do forever did
kidnap but who know maybe gets off but I
want to but I need to know cuz then pop
a bit I can just pull pin the purple
porch when the kids get out of that noon
and coldcock them yeah that's right and
everyone films and out Brian I'm good
I'm no consuming I'll do it with you
for real yeah that's not right
but with unlike how's the security not
hold on it's happened more than once
that was my issue like pulled on when I
first heard about hold up happened more
than once clear that's the craziest
thing I would lose my [ __ ] I'll do get
paranoid and what and you see him again
he's done more than one zero sense you
wanted to disappear yeah
oh he's back y'all weeds back back
before we go dr. Karen event I know I
meant to tell you guys I show time was
in town yesterday I wanted looked at the
new to potential studio spaces for new
firing the kid and for below the belt
and dope location we found Santa Monica
real proper fresh those are closer for
both of us really yeah oh I like that
be ready January 1st you should sign the
paperwork in the next week or two fact
would you see this place right oh it's
still early I don't building very real
Ganesh our building on Park in private
parking Wow right of Santa Monica it
makes me very happy for teen we put a
gym in so you cannot get a spar we don't
have room for that but okay no no mats
cuz I like to roll before don't think
think of Rogen's but no mats no gym
where camp are
inside and just do podcast in there okay
yeah that works but I a bigger than this
waving great yeah oh no I just forgot
about that fact we don't forget all
righty
the next one is this alert that came out
yesterday I'm sure you guys all got it
yeah I didn't get it and I didn't get a
shooting I did but my phone was on
silent it still go crazy I didn't hear
anything about when it's on silent I
heard if you turn your phone off you
turn it on it'll still go off what if
it's silent I don't think it I think it
just buzzes if it's not was the warning
so it's a presidential warning alert
warning so if there's something crazy
like a national disaster something like
that it'll show up on your phone that's
scary and then people are no people are
joking around that so you know Trump
likes to tweet stuff like this is his
way of getting into you like getting to
you closer it could be I didn't send his
message oh yeah but you remember when
the next thing gave up the worse that's
scary this this is a little frightening
left they're like oh let's just just get
into my like why are you trying you know
why are you getting into my phone yeah
well getting the phone's one thing like
I'm not worried about that but them just
I mean they're obviously a VAX if
there's a national kind of thing we all
need to know do I prepare for that makes
sense but for them to test it's a little
scary
okay like what's going on behind scenes
where they have to blast this out right
now we have got another point with like
you are always on video you know this is
just like you're always being watched
mm-hmm this is another example I think
privacy is actually truly dead and we're
right for your home well that's your
Daniel Stern but they can also listen in
to yeah well on your Alexa on your phone
no phone no TV you know when you said
when you press like a you can access the
microphone is that technology can all
free free you because then you can have
countermeasures for that too but yeah
it's still creepy though
yeah all right moving on from this
kratom in Ohio
so Jonathan shop sent us this because
you know I'll take kratom before show
sometimes Jonathan shop J okay so no
name is J
so he sent me this because he's oh he
goes dude I'm I'm reading too much stuff
kratom was bad and this morning I woke
up because I [ __ ] told you
so there's old god there's a few states
though we're creatives band there's
other states where it's it's potentially
they're going through the process now
but there's there's not great news about
kratom it no it's been like this for
years though they try to ban it in 2016
or something and then like nine senators
or a bunch of people sign a bunch of
stuff and then it reversed it and then
on top of the ons it's not an actual
opiate but it bonds to this yeah
receptor yes yes morphine yeah it's
considered we're not morphine but it's
considered an opioid but it doesn't
affect you the same way like a
prescription opiate does and when you
read about it says like this people who
stopped taking had depression stuff like
that but then there's also - the
counter-argument those people who said
they had depression start taking the
Senate help buddy my buddy I wish I
would definitely say listen I've done
real opiates I've done alpha brain I've
taken you know caffeine up the Gazoo
there's something going on with kratom
where it's it's definitely it's not all
positive what what what well no it's not
that I took too much and I got [ __ ]
you know yeah issues but like I take a
very small trace amount now very small
before shows typically but there's
something you know like I can take
creatine I'm sure it does some work if I
inject [ __ ] straight testosterone in
my blood yeah I can definitely tell you
it's working and that's illegal
yeah if I take alpha brain it's a work
100% man and it's safe now if I take two
pills of kratom can feel it oh I can
feel it running in my veins
okay now there's something that so when
you feel it what do you feel I mean does
it make you feel like you're losing
control or do you just feel better
cloudy and nice no cloudy nice like I'm
high chin that's why you take no no why
I take it listen just because it makes
you feel good doesn't mean it's supposed
to be bad for you no like your your
demonizing because it feels good like
imagine imagine you took the feelgood
out of sex like you know for sex you got
to reproduce anyways that's that's why
here I've great example you don't take
caffeine or even caffeine be a similar
but let's just say sex all right you
take the feel-good out of sex no sex not
it does its job well no sex is natural
natural your body produces sperm in the
orgasm it's natural in your body
Creighton's not something natural it
runs through your veins creams are
something that is produced that we take
as a pill for but it's a natural plant
it's a natural tree so is cocaine
cocaine scum no but it's okay so it's
not chemically isn't as I mixed with
other chemicals yeah of course of course
this is not this is ground up so this
opiate if opium and it's and it's be
careful about being natural because
there are a lot of things that are
natural that will kill you
where's your I know but I do think that
kratom from what I have read and what
I've seen is that there it is hey it is
a it seems to be for a lot of people
addictive it seems to have a dosage
where it goes you know where the fine
line take a lot of course you're gonna
feel like woozy and all SS anyway so the
same place Ohio they also made it
illegal to use CBD oil so what tells
that well they can do that you could say
well they also they're gonna ban this so
there you have to take that into
consideration no you don't but look at
the rest of the state there's a to me
that's a little warming when that many
states are banning it's been that way
when I talk to a doctor and you weren't
were you there when I sign that doctor
what doctor he was uh he used to be a
comic he's a doctor he's a wrestler with
least her bowling no well now he's he's
a doctor and I asked Jen cuz chin had
this powder I took the powder
he's really taking I go crate him ever
views heard of it and what do you think
is definitely not enough research going
that's true for you to be taken like
that no really because I have way too
many patients that I know I've been
addicted that stuff because I would hold
off on it yep I'm it really goes I can't
tell you that it's gonna kill you but I
do know I've met a lot of people who are
very addicted to it he wasn't to me
that's alarming
yep I said and I said this chin thing of
it but it's all natural and he'd laughed
in my face are you laugh in your face
cuz it's because it says oh no that wait
so that means nothing if you say it's
all natural that that counts for nominal
shows arsenic I mean obviously no I'll
talk about from the it's a
it's a plant from the earth vodka that's
not talking about her there are
mushrooms there are mushrooms that come
from the earth that'll kill you right
now yeah but we eat other mushrooms that
are fine sharp those kill us absolutely
nothing in terms of whether or not it's
good or safe not safe I'm saying you
guys go do your own research figure out
what's good for you and if it if it
works for you
go for it but don't say like oh it's bad
for everyone but this is how no you're
an addict change can you take your again
defensive like you're pranking me well
I'm defensive so I'm an addict boys or
how about your scene so pass around
anything ever
how about in the show I believe this
actually saves people's lives I do
hundred percent ninety percent so I
think it's important I think there's
some true they might save some people
but I'm telling from a guy who had an
opiate problem when I was fighting did I
get the exact same feeling when I take
this that's a problem I would say
remember I told you I had a vicodin
Norco before for my back pain I've had
that and I have this and I do not get
the same feelings you take this every
day right Jen every day yeah like three
grams of dose you're an addict does but
there's nothing wrong with that I don't
know like I'm gonna coffee yeah you're
fine your phone doesn't seem to affect
well you're definitely an addict but
just I'm not saying that's a problem
okay that's a better way to phrase it
when you say you're an addict it seems
like you're going like oh you're an
addict too you're getting defensive
because we call me an addict of course
I'm about it took off you stopped taking
I don't notice any I'm addicted
officially notice anything different
with no internet
you're very you know you do your job to
the up to you know your optimal level
and so obviously create them whatever
you're doing seems to be working for you
yeah I've never but when people do
certain things you can tell it can get
it can get when somebody's a cokehead
you know you can if I start tripping
around and falling down but I know
functional alcoholic
I don't function people get hot that
every morning they wake up they have to
smoke but I'll call we know you're not
it's not good for you we know for a fact
it's not good for you free drink every
single day yeah we know that we don't
know much about creating again alcohol
yeah so wine is glass of wine a day and
be good for you
glass why are they supposed to be good
for you so there's so many different
variables yeah just do your own research
suppose that and
the freaking addict you know that's a
medic it's if there's nothing wrong and
you love it no three is different so
some people do really well with weed oh
I can't do well with weed that's all
really well with like they can just
drink they can drink hard alcohol and
they feel [ __ ] like Winston Churchill
probably always had some alcohol in his
body and there are people that can
function wait so is with the guys that
you know smoke weed we just ate Joe
Rogan's an addict I don't know I don't
stop in for those burning days strong
okay but he didn't doing it every single
day though alright I don't know if every
single day but he does it a lot so is he
an addict I don't know I don't I don't
know personally enough where if he's
doing everyday if he's doing everyday
yeah like you know Matt the photographer
in Chicago I he's every morning he wakes
up he gets I so he's an addict every
morning now and I what you're not cos
yeah yeah okay here's I have to function
off it I went and I like how you said
that you you drink coffee and a coffee
addict so that makes it better I thought
you'd just be like oh man you're an
addict no yeah listen I'm a sugar addict
I'm a coffee addict
I if I don't work out the endorphins
from working out I'm addicted a lot of
stuff Jen got hot chicks
I mean doesn't mean it's a it's a bad
thing but if if I don't have it it's
trouble okay I sent you one J just sent
me but I mean listen in 10 years when
they banned all [ __ ] kratom they say
it's worse than math and your [ __ ]
binging out and scratching your neck and
yours 38 pounds don't come crying to me
that'd be like less than my head now
we'll get you some good stuff now I
might come out by K this is basically
the limitless pill and the reason we
want to ban it cuz so goddamn good Vega
am I guess still take it yes Tom Cruise
can see story ten days a month but
hasn't seen her in years
ready and guess why not on don't read I
guess why not cuz of science cuz she's
not in Scientology and she's 10 so he
decides not to see her oh he decided he
decided
how [ __ ] crazy is that that to me is
that he chooses not to because she's not
in Scientology wait a minute
wait every person is allowed to see
their child if they wanted to source
tells us revealing custody of a 12 year
old is outlined in his divorce agreement
with oh that's pretty simple you know
how I feel about this you you know that
I have that I have zero time for that
behavior like you don't see your
beautiful as Tom Cruise on see you're
one of my favorite eautiful daughter I
once I have no rustam out my house zero
you and I have children I can't imagine
that I have zero respect if that's true
and I don't know if it's true but if
it's true I have zero respect for that
guy I'd I think he no wonder he's as
[ __ ] up as a human being can get enjoy
your fame enjoy being alone and is it
any wonder he hasn't me I only make a
relationship or whatever he's never feel
like a complete [ __ ] [ __ ] when he's
on his deathbed you know that
relationship with his daughter
and he goes up to not Scientology where
the [ __ ] he believes and he goes oh my
god I'm a [ __ ] idiot I've raised my
entire law yeah I know how to have a
relationship and it was for nothing
you [ __ ] idiot you mission impossible
[ __ ] dope what is wrong with you now
I can't support it now I can't see your
movie somehow dude I don't give a [ __ ]
if you remake Tom Top Gun well if you
make whatever move you want to do you
make Jamie grab to your daughter
my your daughter now you want to see her
she's she's what is she ten twelve it
says you know I'm sorry I'm did I'm just
gonna say this I had a I had a [ __ ]
hour conversation with Tom Cruise about
our daughters because I in fact I think
it's not as my age my daughter's my
daughter's weight twelve years old
fifty-one she loves makes sense that's
creepy
ya know but we had a long talk about our
daughters because my daughter at the
time was two years younger than his he
oh he finessed Joe no no and I got four
now they went through yeah and it was
great because we're talking about all
the things we were worried about in all
things
and this [ __ ] dude this [ __ ] can
you leave that we called finessin bro
and he said yeah go ahead I'm not she's
not in Scientology welcome to the time
has any more to the story isn't there I
don't think so help me so badly to
Scientology
he's bright like nah unless that [ __ ]
converts I'm not a [ __ ] dummy if you
know that's crazy I'm out what else you
got actually crazy to me Tom Cruise also
takes method I feel bad for her his
daughter you know you know what he's
such a [ __ ] loony it might be better
I agree dude maybe Katie Holmes like
that dudes batshit crazy I don't want
her in our Don never been able to make a
relationship you think Tom L Hubbard is
the answer the named Robert Rob Ronelle
Harper his life is living my life is a
movie set and that's what he does and
does he make a good movie yeah he does
he kills it okay but when you're on your
deathbed Mission Possible three ratings
aren't gonna now never have never I
don't have a child if you can't handle
it but whatever all right
maybe she could have converted though
she seems like a normal cool gal who got
caught up with hitting oh yeah that's
what they say yeah yeah but they also
said they like they like prepped her and
like they really do know a relationship
they like broader into and then she like
what one day will come like what the
[ __ ] am i doing and and now she's with
oh she went Scientology very cool Jamie
Foxx with the fattest [ __ ] in Hollywood
Jeana my that's who she's dating all for
quite some I loved and Jamie Foxx
let me let me tell you something there's
on mortality than Tom I'm Jamie Foxx
might be the most talented man Holly I'm
right with you sing check act [ __ ]
just great looks great
come right with you on comedy is come
use me Jamie fun living color and a
stand-up can do no wrong in my the Jamie
Foxx show Oh Jamie Foxx's hands down the
most Afghan had some time with him and
and I wanted you keep dropping names now
tendering me and I'm sure the audience
knows about as well doesn't matter cuz
you liar
no spend some time with them was last
line that's wet had many conversations
Lindsay Lohan it's not true did you want
a case
guys went on a jet ski no no I didn't
act she said you wanna go jet skiing but
I spent I spent that probably three long
no you drop it so many times with me a
little wrong Lindsay Lohan spent enough
time yo J afford it now
Sperry talked to Tom Cruise our has
Jamie twice wanted to be his friend
didn't work out but I was dropping names
bro and and and and hung with Tom Cruise
twice for more than two hours each just
you and him yeah hard time believing
that that's what Tom Cruise just we're
with us at so I did reading with Tom
Cruise and afterwards we hung and all
talked a group of you though yeah it
wasn't you and him while I won 4-2 I
know but then you're in the room and at
a party six months later an Oscar party
where Madonna was I mean you name it the
biggest people Oscar party a phrase good
know how sure and he and I when I told
him I said we did the reading together
for whatever reason we sat there and
talked for during the middle the party
you out for an hour
I'm calm L [ __ ] you can couple two hours
yeah but during the middle of party was
your Tom Cruise in your tux at an Oscar
party sat down and talked no standing
talking yes God and it was no less
I was no less than an hour yeah and had
a good conversation I mean like like
like this it like the kind of
conversation where I was like like I was
like maybe we'll be friends doesn't pop
out for and get then I go out I'm
leaving kind of all at the same time and
his his car pulls up it's an SUV and it
had curtains it had curtains in the
windows son to old school curtain
Scientology like like a the way I'd came
with like a Hearst or some new Bach what
else you got all right I got this hey
have you guys ever done a gender reveal
for your kids no I didn't want to wait
I'm too impatient you know people do it
hey have you ever seen no one have you
seen those but baseball have you seen
the bad genders all that have you seen
those where they go you know they they
do like a ball and they gotta hit it
yeah and the guy [ __ ] goes to hit and
the ball like hits the grandpa a dick or
something like that or he misses or he
just whips and was like a dog on there
like you have no future as a
yeah that's a man but what's this one
all right so this guy did a
gender-reveal and he set up this thing
called Tanner right that's the one where
that bucket it's like an explosive
powder with all that other either the
green I'm sorry either the blue or the
pink for a boy or girl so he shot at it
with a high-power Ralph's rifle in
Arizona it sparked a fire that fire
ended up going burning ups over forty
seven thousand acres ah that's a real
[ __ ] real but he called [ __ ] he called
the authorities right away but it was
too late people are getting very sick
and find like a mother he's supposed to
be fine it costs him 80 or eight million
dollars but he has to pay 100,000 up
front and then pay a portion every month
who is this is the biggest loan of those
guys a Border Patrol agent he didn't
have that money no they're gonna take
your wages but they said they probably
won't gonna they probably got charging
the entire eight notes take it was
definitely a mistake what a [ __ ]
though yeah and so far I guess he's not
telling anyone what the baby was here's
a boy or girl it's kind of a bummer to
those gender reveal things weird yeah
I'm too excited I can't wait that long I
was too crunk yeah and then they leave
the room natural colors and by natural
you know like neutral play neutral
colors it's weird I just curious you
wanted a boy right I wanted a boy it's
weird I wanted a boy off see every dude
wants a boy but then I want a daughter
like when they told us a guy gotta be
cool moon girl so no I want a bunch of
kids oh so don't matter and Brian you
wanted a boy or girl you first solids
are healthy dude the fun matters
seriously cool see ya this is a gross
one the Ryder Cup Brooks koepka did a
tee shot and it landed into the audience
and it made a woman's eye explode her
about this be a hitter orbital no
exploded her [ __ ] eye so she lost
vision a blind Nona lost vision she
blind bro in the right eye for and
imagine you just sitting there for like
crazy accident dude Wow and now she's
suing the piss out of this she's suing
the the the organization not him
because I guess they didn't burn up her
say though have you seen the way they
line up that close as the guy throws no
she's way off and then they go she was
like way in the distance and they said
she goes there's no banister whole she
freak accident like she goes there's no
warrant I had no idea what's going on
but Dunn says that Ryder Cup goes well
we yelled yeah they said there's
multiple iPatch broke with a with the
Ryder Cup flag it's a bummer man that
sucks you're gonna lose your eye
sometimes you guys want to see it happen
yes all right here we go it's give me so
far in the distance though they're young
for now you can't see it it's someone in
the gallery hits someone on the knee in
sold on the knee bit that wasn't no and
then I actually had the pictures if you
want to see yeah please do really yeah
let's go all in hard all right this is
pretty gross is this from barstool this
is from TMZ okay my eyes are watering
already
that's her on the bottom okay there's a
closer image she's a tireless - my cue
ball I have no idea woman man there's a
top full here it is you can tell just by
looking at that the eye is just most
pictures better than I thought though
that's a bummer though missing your
[ __ ] I'm in that sucks
now she's 14 49 and she's very common
composure she was speaking to the media
she said she really didn't feel anything
either oh [ __ ] no no she's apparently
right in the eyeball is that's why
you've been poked in the eye yeah the
hurt so bad oh the worst pain in your
life fall to the ground
are there no nerves your eyeball boy I
got poked my breathing III with a guy
put his finger like all and i pooed I
started crying I was on duty I was so
[ __ ] panicked but it hurts so badly
you've done that you hadn't poked when
you find any many times really [ __ ]
hurt so whoever says there's no nerves
in the eyes full of complete cheese I
guess that when you when you operate
when you do lasix that hurts - Brian
I've had Lee so you have yep that hurts
- all right that stings a little they
have to numb your I have to open up the
first layer and and so so you do have
nervous
I guess when you get something in your
eye you know it you know it I got
something in my eye
it's the word because you can now get
now maybe you're not singing I may be
deep into that [ __ ] jawbreaker and I
yet there's no nerves but this front
layer here it's you I like people that
in your nuts
I like watch my ire my nuts I'm hitting
the ground I'll even people go yeah I
saw a mind they go what is it well can't
see I can't see into my what is it well
if I see any I Todd I don't when you get
poked in the eye or something like a
scratch you ever scratch your retina and
you keep blinking just feels like
there's a piece of here and your eye
yeah god damn dude Iser
numero uno numero numero
what else get Jim oh here's a quick one
so you know this guy right Pacman Jones
for Denver Broncos yes yeah it was like
him he was attacked at the at the
airport in like July yeah that's a while
ago so a while ago he's are the guy that
attacked him oh he has a he's sentenced
to a year in prison
here's the original video too but the
guy was security for the airport right
he was working at a cleaning crew at the
air so for no reason he just starts
taunting Pacman Jones back bay antenna
[ __ ] him up yeah near the end but the
guy asked for it and the guy's a lot
bigger to lot taller new Dallas Cowboys
so he pushes pac-man right now and then
pack my starts to swing man
he sleeps him right yeah it's like an
awkward punch there's a left punch like
oh right push and then he's already out
right there
and then kicked him in the head thinking
that dude sense for a year in prison
he's just for being a dumbass yeah fine
knocked out and a year in prison I think
as it was at an airport hole there's
something wrong with that guy said
terrorist threats to it I'm not sure
what might be a big like Dallas Cowboys
fan or whatever it is all pac-man and
when you pop off to those get listen
it's not Twitter so when you talked to
[ __ ] to real people they don't like it
man
to deal with the consequence yeah and he
was phenomenal and a different kind of
athlete so [ __ ] off plates where the
limit has nothing to it heard he had a
lot of uh like problems before tea
though
pac-man yeah first of all the chapters
yeah no one say he's a great it wasn't
like a stellar one so let's say all the
problems I'm injured - no no
yeah no he got suspended non-stop
non-stop complete bonehead complete
bonehead yeah I think he paralyzed some
dude he was in a fight okay like he hit
so hard
alright he's a bonehead always has been
what else yeah all right the na mo
player though yeah I'm sure you guys
know this already louis c.k went back to
the Comedy Cellar yeah on Sunday believe
us all claps and no boos yeah so I have
the audio here if you want to hear yeah
but also then they told people's coming
this time right no it's still surprise
Wow
here we go yeah guess what most of
Americans don't give a [ __ ] yep
they just don't I'm sorry well I think
they give a [ __ ] about the me to move it
they don't give a [ __ ] about what he did
right cuz it wasn't right
his case is a little dip yeah
he says something in the end in there
yeah I think they look at it a lot of
people on fish that was it good friends
I'm glad he's back he's hilarious it
doesn't surprise me I'd said from day
one he would be back and he'd be glad
he's back I don't think it'd be this
good but I know when and I don't think
you really special is onna do very well
yeah his is it different than most of
these me to movement things so this is a
little different he has permission to
just a mission with Jack off yeah I
think his is creepy and just peeps very
creepy they're like well he's but it's
not like you're touching on it's gross
still yeah all right how about this we
talked about this before Adam Adam
Sandler's Netflix special it's coming
out October 23rd have you seen the
trailer no this looks pretty different I
think I even posted it this is
interesting
automatically blast out there some of
the songs again it looks like it's a
bunch of everything he's doing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm very intrigued all right all right
it's very different where do you do it
after you know chin I'll find out here
I'm so it's a couple when I say I'm all
leagues I mean I'm all [ __ ] in um
he's such a monster 100% fresh
I'm scent fresh but you know so do you
ever see he was such a big star remember
he has lunch lady sloppy sloppy joe yeah
sloppy joe like he had all the singles
from you know he had all his music you
know he went on tour with all that so he
did like kind of a hybrid stand-up
comedy show with his music I love him
have you ever I love program I used to
watch all that [ __ ] have you ever seen
Adam Sandler go on YouTube Adam
Sandler's concert I'm talking massive
yes yes there's [ __ ] beach balls and
it's insane concert yeah yeah without
you shot an HBO special can't wait what
is this one is on the copter October
23rd
okay on that foot despite the whole
thing but this is look at this this is
the HBO special now how big you was when
Billy Madison happy gilmore that kid is
a stud yes good voice I think here we go
well yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
interesting stop it I don't think he has
like a straight up stand-up comedy
special it's a kind of show often got in
got in got Saturday Night Live and then
you know what though like even with uh
like a lot of the guys told him like
David Spade and Chris Rock would tell
him like even when they didn't sign I
live those guys would still do spots
that night yeah they say those got to
stand up yeah
even now David Spade can't see grinding
for the counter all the time yeah hard
to do when you're when you're in that I
know a lot about what that schedule is
for someone like Adam Sandler I bet dude
nightmare I mean you write all night
it's really hard to pretty much anything
else and you use one the main writer yes
it's really really hard you know you got
fired yeah do you guys know you got
fired from Senate life you know that's
why he's never hosted it I didn't use
that fire by Lorne Michaels fired some
one that NBC Universal execs didn't want
him up back so he's a guy cool and he
laughs he got fired I get fired and then
that's why he's never hosted never I did
there's no one wonder why he's the Adam
Sandler has never hosted that's Chris
Rock that makes you know that was just
some of her fans yeah yeah crazy right I
got fired from MADtv and I didn't go on
to be him you got fired too all right
yeah what how did they let you go B they
said you just didn't come up with enough
characters but they didn't tell me last
minute it was really weird but I didn't
I I agreed with him I wasn't at the time
I'm sure you did it
I did I nope I I agreed with them
because I knew you I just wasn't
thinking it I just wasn't into it I
wasn't working as hard well I just
didn't know how to do
I hadn't had any experience in writing
sketches no yes I didn't know and
characters I didn't have any experience
I just found my way in there
silly goose yeah and I had to use my
instincts but I was I was going by
instinct and a lot of those people had a
lot of experience with The Groundlings
and all that really really experienced
and frankly there were people like Will
Sasso who are in the wings and they were
better at than I was and so I've always
been you know a little as though you're
always sad it's always a bummer it's
always so he's an eagle and and you know
you hope that you're gonna go on but I
went a long time without working after
that a long time and you know years
years years years did they give you a
heads up and say like hey you should
probably not their fault and and it's
it's it they [ __ ] like look you know
what happens this is what happened there
are people that were better than I was
at that for what they were looking for
benefits like you see damon wayans quit
lethal weapon it's they're in their
third season no you just got done
shooting it and he was just on set and
they're doing areas like yeah I'm
quitting you think this is enough time
where they can find replace me because
I'm too old for this [ __ ] cuz I miss too
many family things I miss my kids my
grand my money I guess I'm too old for
this [ __ ]
he's on that set all the time doing skis
I'm over IRA tall I just my like we're
done shooting I quit
you know they replace the other guy
already too cuz he was a shoot that TV
show and you're doing that drama I wish
people could see what it really means
you're there 16 hours a day and and and
you're waking up at 5:00 and you're
getting home at what a door and you're
there all day and the mundane nature of
it cuz not funny yeah you're doing this
thing with the gun you're coming around
the corner and you keep doing from
different angles it can get super
tedious you're missing and you're
missing everything that's what he said
he's I'm too old for this [ __ ] missing
everything
Wayne brothers just one more
all right this is an American Airlines
passenger who just wouldn't stop doing
pull-ups no no swim bro baggage thing
like gonna top he just kept doing
pull-ups someone walked by him he's
leaning on it and he's like what didn't
do pools try something and then he
should started doing pull-ups and then
they kept him to stop and he would not
stop
he's he was drunk is there a picture of
him there's no picture he was with the
lady and two dogs the eunuchs the boss
and so they diverted the plane dude if I
had a dime it's an event or a stand-up
gig and this morons doing pull-ups yeah
wait did [ __ ] reroute the plane how
did you do not do you think he was
arrested no no so it says they have no
record of him being arrested they just
kicked him up I have a threatening
anyone yeah just wants to work out
ruining everyone else's day maybe you
know I don't cook night I did what
happened 20 years did they in 20 years I
know the showing of Max was 30 yeah he
killed a guy on the set of venom over
and hit another we've seen that video
yeah you seen over the disc terrifying
they give 28 years huh that's a bad man
he's been in prison like on and off
nights you know his son says that to
Pakistan alive recently got some pretty
crazy right yeah I also don't have a dad
so so sugar will get out when he's 83
years he's 53 I bet he runs prison oh
wow people probably Louisville nobody
has great stories till I be he's a real
hit there he's [ __ ] though Manson also
way to go and you're wrapped we ran over
someone real badass and now you're
[ __ ] man now you're in prison for
basically the rest of your life hmm
mm-hmm good job get Kirov at be done at
chin that's pretty much it
shoutout to Suge Knight shoutout to Suge
Knight um boys and girls did do you're
gonna be buddy I'm in Utah the 10th and
12th of October that's wise guys all
four shows are almost sold out as it 4
shows 1890 it's 5 shows all 5 shows are
almost sold out get tickets now and then
after that I'm in San Francisco Cobb's
November 2nd and 3rd I want to come to
that San Francisco yeah oricon you'll
see I want to open for T's do it
Connolly yeah let's do it
I'd really like that right let's do it
[ __ ] ass I'll give you just a dog
you get six minutes give me six minutes
six minutes would that be can we have
super fun let's do it do your mind yeah
I'll get your room all right if you pay
me back
there's cops I'm Cisco 1112 Sacramento
punchline 16th 17th and then just
announced New York City I see yeah I see
on the ground
I'm coming New York City to Gotham
comedy club that is November 30th
through December 1st A's tickets just
one on sale the New Mexico the 7th and
8th those are almost sold out t fat K
calm see you soon you tall Europe 10th
through the 12th get them T Phadke calm
that's Brian
I'm Brendan this is a fine kid we're out